wir schauen auf dem nächsten
tagesordnungspunkt und geht es um zwei
anträge aus der afg fraktion die sich
beschäftigen mit der inflationsrate hier
im land zum einen hat die afg einen
antrag vorgelegt der heißt inflation
realistisch berechnen einführung von
warenkörben für den wöchentlichen
großeinkauf und den täglichen einkauf
das sowohl den besseren vergleich der
preise dienen und ein zweiter antrag der
fdp fraktion bei diesem
tagesordnungspunkt jetzt lautet raus aus
der station falle eine wirtschaftliches
fitnessprogramm für deutschland musste
her und er hat die afg so ziemlich alles
reingepackt was sie aus diversen anderen
kontexten auch schon fordert
beispielsweise die uneingeschränkte
nutzung von kohle und kernkraftwerken
bürokratieabbau et cetera leif erik
ordentlich am pult und erläutert alles
weitere gaskrise explodierte energie und
verbraucherpreise energieknappheit und
fehlende versorgungssicherheit gestörte
lieferketten die rückkehr der euro krise
sinkenden exportzahlen an der
supermarktkasse sieht jeder wie sich die
inflation immer weiter in die geldbörsen
frist gleichzeitig rutscht deutschland
in eine wirtschaftliche stagnation
möglicherweise sogar in eine rezession
bei einem ausbleiben der gaslieferungen
rechnen experten mit einem rückgang der
wirtschaftsleistung um 12,7 prozent mit
einem verlust von 5,6 millionen
arbeitsplätzen das alles sollte uns
wahrlich alarmieren aber diese
bundesregierung redet worüber heute
morgen den ganzen morgen über neue
windräder stadt schnell dafür zu sorgen
dass unsere energieversorgung wieder
sicher wird das ist eine
unverantwortliche politik
sie wollen wir dafür mehr für strom
hohenstadt schnellsten dafür zu sorgen
dass unsere kernkraftwerke weiterlaufen
und vier damit ja auch gas für die
verstromung einsparen können betreiber
tüv lieferanten für brennstäbe sagen es
geht aber sie unternehmen nichts und
klammern sich an ihre ideologische
traumtänzerei es ist an der zeit jetzt
aufzuwachen wir haben keine zeit mehr
also werfen sie endlich den
ideologischen ballast von bord und
kommen sie zu energie politischen
vernunft
und was tun sie gegen die inflation
glauben sie wirklich dass sie die mit
temporären trost plötzlichen für drei
monate im zaum halten können mit kleinen
give aways bei denen sie auch noch die
rentner vergessen das wird nicht
funktionieren wir müssen die inflation
wirksam bremsen bevor die lohn preis
spirale in gang kommt bevor die
stagnation falle zuschnappt und wenig
mehr herauskommen es ist natürlich vor
allem die pflicht und schuldigkeit der
ezb jetzt zu handeln die geldschwemme
die jahrelange geldschwemme endlich zu
beenden und ernsthaft gegen die
inflation vorzugehen sie tut es aber
nach wie vor nicht um die opfer hoch
verschuldeten südländer über wasser zu
halten stichwort italien 150 prozent
schuldenquote ja natürlich ist die ezb
unabhängig aber sie ist allein der
preisstabilität verpflichtet und deshalb
muss sie handeln und wenn sie es nicht
tut dann muss die bundesregierung dies
mindestens laut und deutlich sagen es
muss an gemacht werden damit die
zinsschritte schneller und deutlicher
kommen aber auch der staat kann
natürlich unten muss etwas tun gegen
inflation aber das reicht eben kein
konzentriertes kaffeekränzchen im
kanzleramt mit die tarifpartner
das ist mein ernst ein schönes
kennenlerntreffen reicht nicht wir
müssen schnell handeln wir müssen
schnell handeln in dieser situation aber
der kanzlerin immer noch wie eine tüte
durch die gegend regieren norden sagen
würden und versucht das ganze
auszusitzen es funktioniert in dieser
lage nicht
deshalb brauchen wir jetzt ein schnelles
ein wirtschaftliches fitnessprogramm für
deutschland um ein abgleiten in die
womöglich schwerste krise seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg zu verhindern ihnen
ist der ernste lage immer noch nicht
bewusst ganz offensichtlich
und deshalb brauchen wir jetzt nicht
noch mehr windräder in aller erster
linie sondern wir brauchen eine
entlastung 24 zu hohen steuern und
abgaben vor allem auf die energie denn
es ist gerade ihre vermurkste
energiepolitik die inflation massiv
befeuert hat ja wir haben eine grüne
inflation auch wenn sie es nicht hören
wollen wir haben eine grüne inflation
eeg-umlage co2 abgabe netzentgelte
energiesteuern und und und ja sie
wollten doch teure energie und jetzt
haben die bürger sie bekommen zusätzlich
jetzt befeuert durch die
energieknappheit
experten haben berechnet dass ein vier
personen haushalt in diesem jahr bis zu
3700 euro mehr für heizen und für strom
ausgeben muss vier spielen das erste mal
echte existenz amt und diese dramatische
entwicklung verantwortenden großteils
sie und auch ihre vorgänger und deswegen
müssen auch gerade sie jetzt dringend
handeln und diese inflationäre
entwicklung stoppen
[Applaus]
wir müssen runter mit den staatlichen
preisbestandteile war sprit öl gas und
strom und zwar nicht für drei monate
sondern dauerhaft die mini
trostpflästerchen reichen und ich kann
doch jeder über den august hinaus
schauen und sehen was kommt deshalb muss
jetzt gehandelt werden die bürger
brauchen ein glaubwürdiges
dauerhaftes zeichen dass sie entlastet
werden von der energie steuer von der
stromsteuer können runter aufs minimum
den co2 abgabe geschafft im übrigen auch
der sony den die unternehmen nach wie
vor zu großen teilen bezahlen müssen
glaubwürdig und dauerhaft runter von
diesen preisen und vom boden weg das ist
der weg
das schont den geldbeutel sofort und
sorgten auch dafür dass die
inflationserwartungen sich noch weiter
steigen die lohn preis spirale ist die
große gefahr und deshalb muss schnell
gehandelt werden und dafür ist die
bundesregierung da auch wenn sie jetzt
sagen das ist nicht bezahlbar dann sage
ich ihnen natürlich geht das wir haben
in der aktuellen haushaltsdebatte
darüber gesprochen wir haben ein
einsparvolumen von 160 milliarden euro
markiert der steuerzahlerbund sieht
sinnlose subvention in höhe von 47
milliarden selbst der
bundesfinanzminister sagt ja die ganzen
subventionen für e-autos die können
weltordnung her würden technisch noch
einen ersten schuss den können beck und
die müssen auch weg da hat er recht aber
er wird sich diese aber natürlich nicht
durchsetzen dennoch es wäre geboten wir
brauchen keine neuen ausgabenprogramme
wir können sinnloser ausgabenprogramme
streichen und dafür die bürger und
unternehmen endlich dauerhaft entlassen
das ist der richtige weg kommen sie
bitte schnell zum tor es ist dringend
vor mir eine große krise hinein
wirtschaft
leif erik holm ist
wirtschaftspolitischer sprecher der fdp
fraktion auch einer der
stellvertretenden fraktionsvorsitzenden
hat hier bezug genommen auch die beiden
anträge außer af.de diesen
tagesordnungspunkt zugrunde liegen und
dazu jetzt taxis mehmet ali aus der spd
fraktion
als der antrag der afg kam habe ich mich
hingesetzt und habe mir überlegt wie
könnte denn so ein warenkorb aussehen
den die ard macht und wenn man sich dann
die inhalte genauer anguckt kam mir so
die gedanken fährt als transportmittel
anstatt auto videokassette anstatt film
streaming ja quasi so normal 30 100
jahre zurück und da zeigt doch
eigentlich in was für einer geisteswelt
die afd ist in welcher
rückschrittlichen welt die afg ist ihr
antrag jetzt wieder einmal
undifferenziert und fachlich auch
einfach nicht richtig
ja natürlich dazu komme ich nur dazu
komme ich noch sie verbreiten ja neben
der ganzen wirtschaft leugnung der die
üblichen narrativer also immer an allem
ist die eu schuld die flüchtlinge sind
schuld vertrauensverlust der bevölkerung
in den staat und die formierung von
bundesämtern da fragt man sich ja
eigentlich wenn man weiß auf was von der
bewegung sie kommen und bei soviel
ökonominnen und ökonomen in ihrer partei
dass bildung zwar wichtig ist aber man
muss auch bildung anwenden können und
das sieht man an ihrem antrag dass es
ähnlich gelungen ist
bleiben wir mal im bereich der
energiepreise meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren so grundsätzlich handelt es
sich hierbei um angebots im
platzangebots inflation das kann im
übrigen passieren bei oligopolistischen
strukturen auf den märkten kann das
immer mal passieren
nur was wir als sozialdemokraten in
unserer zeit demokraten einfach nicht
akzeptieren können ist ja der umstand
dass wir hier mit preiserhöhungen zu tun
haben die rein auf basis von
spekulations preisen geschehen und da
muss der staat und da reagiert auch der
staat im rahmen der sozialen
marktwirtschaft
das ist auch der richtige weg
was ich aber weiß ich aber nicht glaube
das gehört zur wahrheit dazu dass ich
nicht glaube dass diese situation durch
die die selbstregulierung der märkte zu
gunsten der privaten haushalte
abgefangen wird das muss man ganz genau
wissen jetzt ist gerade der staat jetzt
ist die regierung gefordert jetzt ist
das parlament gefordert den menschen zu
helfen was man aber erst recht nicht
akzeptieren darf ist der umstand dass
der krieg dazu genutzt wird insbesondere
von den energiekonzernen gewinne und
profite zu erhöhen auf kosten derer die
darunter leiden und das sind sie und ich
das sind die bürgerinnen bürger und da
müssen wir ganz klar sagen das darf
nicht passieren und deshalb muss man
auch reagieren meine damen und herren
man kann immer sagen wenn der staat
eingreift wenn der staat sich in den
marktmechanismus ein mich dann ist das
planwirtschaft kann man immer ganz
pauschal sagen aber wir haben eine
soziale marktwirtschaft und das darf der
staat in krisensituation machen und das
tun wir auch jetzt meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren noch eine eigene
persönliche meinung auch ich weiß dass
das vielleicht manchmal nicht gehört
werden will wir können steuern senken
wir können abgaben senken auf der
anderen seite und die energiepreise
günstiger zu machen das muss aber auch
bei den leuten ankommen und das haben
wir ja auch mit dem tank rabatt
teilweise erreicht haben uns viel mehr
gewünscht wir haben die möglichkeiten
noch nicht ausgeschöpft
die möglich sind es gibt die
möglichkeiten darüber zu reden über
höchstpreise mindestpreise ist noch
nicht ausgeschöpft muss man immer
vorsichtig sein aber meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren ich glaube schon dass
ein sauberer mix sich lohnen kann weil
erst recht deutschland für die
energiekonzerne ein nicht ab ein nicht
relevanter markt ist und absatz relevant
ist für die energie-konzerne wir müssen
hier die bürgerinnen und bürger schützen
lass uns über alle möglichkeiten reden
und verhandlungen wollen wir ja auch
nicht in eine rezession sein pa nicht in
eine langfristige rezession deshalb ist
es umso wichtiger jetzt präventiv zu
agieren um dann später antizyklisch
handeln zu müssen
was wiederum sehr ärgerlich ist wenn man
dann ließ in solchen anträgen wie die
bei der afg und ich halte es als
unsäglich wenn sie behaupten dass die
zahlen des statistischen bundesamtes ja
nicht die realen inflationswerte
darstellen das ist unsäglich sie stellen
die das statistische bundesamt so als
würde es die zahlen bestätigen das ist
nicht die tatsache die zahlen sind real
die zahlen sind real wovon wovon wovon
wovon wir alles nicht eine ahnung haben
wenn wir auf sie hören würden dann wäre
das land schon lange gegen die wand
gefahren
wir haben in der ampelkoalition darüber
gesprochen was für entlastungspaket wie
in die wege bringen und vieles geschieht
ja auch der kanzler hat die konzertierte
aktion
angekündigt und das wird auch zu einem
erfolg führen viel wichtiger ist es
jetzt maßnahmen und instrumente zu
verabschieden die den bürgerinnen und
bürger helfen und lieber afd von ihnen
hört man nichts außer kritik
rechtspopulismus und ich wünsche mir in
diesem zusammenhang vielleicht auch
bisschen mehr zurückhaltung auch in
ihren äußerungen vielen dank
[Applaus]
dr klaus wiener für die unionsfraktion
ja frau präsidentin verehrte kolleginnen
verehrte kollegin es gibt drei arten von
lügen einfache lügen verdammte lügen und
statistiken dieser durchaus
bemerkenswerte satz wir in einem
englischen politiker zugeschrieben und
das ist nicht der der heute
zurückgetreten ist an diesen satz habe
ich nicht aber erinnert gefühlt als ich
ihren antrag gelesen habe darum weil sie
suggerieren dass hier etwas nicht stimmt
wird der inflations messungen klang ja
gerade schon mal an dem möchte auch ich
hier ausdrücklich widersprechen das
statistische bundesamt betreibt einen
sehr großen aufwand um ein verlässliches
bild über die inflationsentwicklung zu
geben es werden 60.000 haushalte befragt
es werden 300.000 güter mit den preisen
erfasst zum teil sogar in echtzeit auf
basis dieser großen wirklich großen
datenmenge wird dann die inflationsrate
berechnet aber die entscheidende frage
ist doch mit welchem ziel und die
antwort ist damit wir wirksame
wirtschaftspolitik auf
gesamtwirtschaftlicher ebene machen
können damit wir die inflation so messen
wie sie ist denn sie sagt etwas aus über
den auslastungsgrad der wirtschaft und
damit ist sie wichtiger signalgeber zum
beispiel für die finanzpolitik
bis die inflation zu niedrig darf man
und das betone ich hier auch
vorübergehend gerne mal ein bisschen
mehr geld ausgeben ist sie aber zu hoch
dann darf man nicht immer neue
ausgabenprogramme auflegen denn damit
verschlimmert man das eigentliche
inflationsproblem so wie es die ampel
gerade macht also zum teil selbst
verstehen
ein großes unbehagen hatte ich ja als
ich den koalitionsvertrag gelesen habe
viele wünsche 0 gegenfinanzierung aber
das ist in sachen neuverschuldung und
damit auch zusätzlich induzierter
inflation so schlimm kommen würde damit
habe ich nicht gerechnet aber
auch für die geldpolitik
auch für die geldpolitik ist inflation
ein wichtiger gradmesser das erleben wir
gerade dieser tage wo die ezb zumindest
ansatzweise über eine normalisierung
ihrer geldpolitik nachdenkt aber genauso
wie sich die europäische geldpolitik
nicht am preisniveau einzelner länder
ausrichten kann darf sie geld politik
auch nicht mit blick auf einzelne
gesellschaftliche gruppen machen so wie
sie das im antrag formulieren sie hat
nur ein ziel und das lautet
preisniveaustabilität und das muss sie
im durchschnitt für alle länder und für
alle menschen im euro raum erfüllen
etwas anderes ist es natürlich wenn es
darum geht besonders betroffene gruppen
zu entlasten das kann man das sollte man
aus sozialen erwägungen heraus machen
allerdings nur indem man
belastungsspitzen wegnimmt und nicht die
gießkanne einsetzt sowie die ampel ist
gerade tut tank rabatt energie
pauschalen euro ticket all das weist in
die falsche richtung hier wird geld
einfach ziellos verschwendet
und genau aus den genannten gründen sind
inflationszahlen die einzelnen gruppen
in den fokus nehmen auch nur gefühlt
im zweiten antrag geht es um die stadt
formations falle wobei im grunde das ja
bereits eine verharmlosung ist was uns
wirtschaftlich droht wenn die ampel so
weiter macht der begriff setzt sich
zusammen aus zwei begriffen zum einen
stagnation also wirtschaftlicher
stillstand und aus inflation hohe
inflationsraten haben wir ja bereits
wirtschaftlich kann es aber durchaus
noch schlimmer kommen denn in einer
rezession stagniert die
wirtschaftleistung ja nicht sie fehlt
und das ist möglicherweise schon sehr
weiter fall deshalb muss die ampel jetzt
handeln weil das regulatorische pendelt
so weit ausgeschlagen ist brauchen wir
ein belastungsmoratorium
gerade die vorgaben von der europäischen
haben in den letzten jahren überhand
genommen aber die werden von weiten
teilen der ampel ja mit begeisterung
aufgenommen an der taxonomie passt ihn
doch nur eines nicht das gas und
kernkraft als nachhaltig eingestuft
wurden so wie gestern noch einmal vom
europäischen parlament bestätigt wir
brauchen noch dringend schnellere
planungs und genehmigungsverfahren und
auch hier springt die ampel zu kurz wenn
sie fast ausschließlich auf den ausbau
der windkraft rekrutiert was zu tun ist
haben wir hier vor einigen wochen mit
einem dezidierten antrag dargestellt
klar der wurde abgelegt aber da stand
viel gutes drin vielleicht gucken sie
noch mal heimlich rein ich denke das
wäre sinnvoll
unser
unser fraktionsvorsitzender friedrich
merz hat ihr gestern an dieser stelle zu
recht darauf hingewiesen dass die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit unserer wirtschaft
gerade unter den jetzt geänderten
rahmenbedingungen dringend gestärkt
werden muss wir müssen unsere
unternehmen steuerlich entlasten das
fordern wir seit jahren aber das war ja
mit der spd in die zu machen so wie
vieles andere auch nicht und wir müssen
den unternehmen luft zum atmen geben und
nicht immer neue vorgaben erfinden was
wir tun müssen die liste ist lang und
das sind auch keine rezepte aus der
wirtschafts politischen mottenkiste wie
ich gestern hier von ihren auftritt von
den grünen herren musste hören musste
wenn sie das wirklich glauben dass das
rezepte aus der wirtschafts politischen
mottenkiste sind dann müssen sie
aufpassen dass aus der sogenannten
fortschritt koalition keine
wirtschaftlichen abstiegs koalition wird
2005 war deutschland der kranke mann
europas sie erinnern sich vielleicht
2005 das war als die rot-grüne regierung
abgewählt wurde 2009 10 waren wir die
stärkste volkswirtschaft europas die
wachstumslokomotive auf dem kontinent
ich bin wirklich gespannt wo wir in
dreieinhalb jahren stehen werden ich
ahne daran nichts gutes was jetzt
passiert und da wiederhole ich auch
gerne in unserem fraktionsvorsitzenden
was jetzt passiert ist allein ihre
verantwortung vielen dank
klaus wiener aus der unionsfraktion
mitglied im ausschuss für umwelt
naturschutz und auch verbraucherschutz
hat jetzt die hartz reform aus dem jahr
2003 mal kurz und praktisch gefallen
lassen wir schauen dem gegen auf die
talente check fraktion bündnis 90/die
grünen und da ist der
wirtschaftspolitischer sprecher
wie bei dr wie nah es würde schon zu
raten auch einen kritischen blick auf
die einstufung der taxonomie zu werfen
gerade was das thema inflation angeht
wenn sie sich gerade situation in
frankreich anschauen mit der atomenergie
die hälfte der kraftwerke ist
abgeschaltet die preise explodieren und
die gaskraft spotmarktpreise sind
sechsfach momentan also wir haben eine
preis explosion gerade bei diesen
energieträgern das jetzt als nachhaltig
einzustufen ist wirklich ein fehler
führte es nicht nach vorne wir brauchen
erneuerbare energien einsparungen das
ist der weg nach vorne auch was
inflation anruf
versäumen sie haben in ihrem antrag
vorgeschlagen den solidaritätszuschlag
vollständig abzuschaffen der ist normal
aber im letzten jahr schon von 90
prozent der einkommensbezieher
abgeschafft worden und zwar für die
unteren 90 prozent was das wiederum
helfen soll die inflation zu bekämpfen
wenn ich es die letzten zehn prozent in
der kaufkraft stärke das müssen wir noch
mal erklären das habe ich nicht
verstanden das macht überhaupt keinen
sinn
was sinn macht ist das was die koalition
getan hat nämlich gezielt zu entlasten
insbesondere die dies notwendig haben
dass nur ein euro ticket auch in der
fläche ein riesenerfolg aber natürlich
auch die zuschüsse für wohngeldempfänger
oder eben auch für menschen mit
sozialleistungen dort haben wir gezielt
angesetzt auch der grundfreibetrag auf
die mittelschicht zu entlasten 30
milliarden euro auf den weg gebracht in
kürzester zeit ich denke das kann sich
sehen lassen was die koalition hier auf
den weg gebracht hat
und es passiert nicht vergessen dürfen
wir haben einen umfassenden angebots
schock
anders als in den usa wo die inflation
stück weit auch getrieben ist durch
staatliches handeln durch ein
umfangreiches konjunkturpaket auch von
joe biden oder eben auch durch störungen
im bereich dienstleistungen industrie da
sind die preise schon angeheizt gewesen
haben wir hier ganz zentral durch die
entwicklung der fossilen energie preise
eine inflation getrieben die der
minister robert beckmann ist startklar
kellner ist jetzt hier für ihn mit
tatkraft und das haben wir heute und
morgen auch noch einmal mit aller kraft
acht gesetzespakete jetzt auf den weg
gebracht zu diversifizieren
energieeinsparung zu ermöglichen
erneuerbarer energien auf den weg zu
bringen damit wir uns nicht mehr so
abhängig machen von dieser afd inflation
die wir haben denn das ist es doch am
ende das haben sie doch immer gefordert
dass wir abhängig sind von russland und
das war der fehler und das wollen wir
nicht mehr
nun ist die inflation eine hohe
belastung für viele menschen zum
beispiel beim einkaufen aber auch bei
der frage des urlaubs wenn jemand eine
gas kostenrechnung hat jetzt über den
winter die zwei- bis dreitausend euro
höher sein könnte im durchschnittswert
bei 120 quadratmeter wohnung für vier
personen dann ist das für viele menschen
ein monatsgehalt gemeint ist es sogar
noch mehr das ist sozialer sprengstoff
da werden wir auch noch mal drüber reden
müssen wie wir daran gehen im herbst
vorgang ist aber die aufgabe auch zu
gucken wie wir investieren können wir in
dieser zeit wo wir in die verschuldung
auf der einen seite gehen aber genauso
auch gucken dass wir in der zukunft
zukunftsfähig handeln und darum geht es
jetzt mit diesen paketen der
energiewende mit diesen entlastungspaket
wie auf den weg gebracht haben
zielgerichtet auf der einen seite
ausgeben aber entschlossen investieren
in die zukunft damit wir nicht mehr in
solche abhängigkeiten gedacht
jetzt ist es was die union angeht ja
immer so dass zum beispiel von ihnen dr
wieder die reden differenziert sind die
anträge sind nicht so differenziert bei
der frage der energie steuerersenkungen
zum beispiel gehen sie in einen bereich
wenn ich das ausrechnen würde wenn wir
wahrscheinlich von 40 milliarden euro
rechnen dass wir einfach nur kosten
senken indem wir die steuern sinken in
diesem bereich die mitnahme effekte die
wir zu erwarten hätten und eben auch die
frage ob es denn sinnvoll ist gerade im
bereich der energie die energie
günstiger zu machen für breite
gesellschaftsschichten die dann wiederum
einen nachfolger effekte schaffen das
muss man doch mal in frage stellen ob
das ein richtiger weg ist die inflation
zu bekämpfen ich glaube es ist besser
zielgerichtet zu helfen als zu sagen wir
gehen bei den energiesteuern auf ein
niveau was sie fordern das scheint mir
nicht vernünftig zu sein
die inflation ist auch ein thema
natürlich jetzt dass uns zählt im
bereich der wertschöpfungsketten der
lieferketten wir haben nicht nur die
energiepreise wir haben auch schon seit
corona vor corona china serie cupid die
problematik dass auch die handelspolitik
ein stückweit gestört ist wenn ganze
märkte sich sozusagen abschotten oder
abgeschottet werden durch einzelnes
handeln die containerschiffe die er
nicht nur in shanghai stehen sondern
jetzt auch in der nordsee das sind
natürlich dinge die wir nicht
kurzfristig beeinflussen können deswegen
ist es auch richtig dass die
bundesregierung
eine neue progressive handelsstrategie
auf den weg bringen und sagt wir müssen
uns mit mehr partnern ein boot setzen am
besten mit partner die die gemeinsamen
werte mit uns haben damit wir auch
verlässlicher gestalten können auch im
bereich der handelspolitik und
nicht zuletzt nicht zuletzt heißt das
natürlich wir uns jetzt auch all die
investition im bereich automatisierung
digitalisierung fortschritt innovation
nach vorne zu bringen auch wenn wir
jetzt in einer krisensituation sind
dürfen wir nicht nachlassen bei den
investitionen deswegen zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt zu sagen die schuldenbremse
ist sakrosankt das ist nicht der
zwingende weg darüber werden wir
möglicherweise im herbst auch noch mal
reden müssen aber am ende muss es davon
abhängen dass wir die
zukunftsinvestition nach vorne stellen
wenn uns das gelingt dann können wir
auch in dieser fortschritt koalition
gegen den abstieg kämpfen dass es genau
das was wir tun das wir getan haben in
den letzten wochen monaten
sozial sozial zu handeln zielgerichtet
zu investieren und ökonomisch nicht
dinge zu tun die auch gar keinen sinn zu
ergeben nämlich dort zu entlasten wo es
die menschen gar nicht notwendig haben
und damit nachfrage zu stimulieren die
inflation wieder anzutreiben das war der
vernünftige kurs der letzten wochen und
monate den wollen wir gemeinsam
beibehalten darum geht es jetzt und es
ist eine schwierige zeit und das müssen
immer wieder auch betonen für viele
menschen in diesem land deswegen ist es
wichtig gezielt dort zu entlassen wo es
notwendig ist aber es ist nicht
notwendig jetzt in die breite zu gehen
und zu sagen jeder muss das tragen
können sondern wir müssen jetzt handeln
nach vorne darum geht es nicht danke
ihnen für diese diskussion
die bieter janitschek mal dass
wirtschaftspolitischer sprecher der
fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen in dieser
debatte über zwei anträge zur inflation
neben deutschland und wie man sie
bekämpfen könnte dazu jetzt christian
görke aus der linksfraktion
hat ja wieder mal versucht ihr so ihr
image mit diesen anträgen ein bisschen
aufzupolieren aber meine damen und
herren von der afg sie sind nicht die
partei des kleinen mannes das gegenteil
ist der fall den markt radikal
die partei für steuergeschenke für die
reichen das haben sie ja eben auch
selbst erzählt
sie brauchen da auch ja nicht verwundert
schauen das
wirtschaftsforschungsinstitut zdb hat ja
mal ihre pläne noch mal ein bisschen
beleuchtet auch die anderer parteien und
da steht folgendes drin schwarz auf weiß
ich fast dass mal zusammen kein anderes
programm sorgt für weniger entlastung
bei kleinen einkommen als iris kein
anderes programm mit last
spitzenverdienerinnen und
spitzenverdiener stärker als iris das
sind die fakten und dann sind wir mal
bei den fakten grundsteuer abschaffen
wollen die streichen grunderwerbsteuer
wollen sie streichen erbschaftsteuer
wollen sie streichen jetzt wollen sie
den rest soli streichen vermögenssteuer
wollen sie auch nicht ja das sind alle
steuergeschenke genau für die für diese
politik war für die reichen und deshalb
heißt mit ihrem programm nicht
deutschland aber normal sondern in
deutschland eher neo liberal darüber
meine damen und herren können doch ihre
heute in anträgen nicht hinwegtäuschen
sie schreiben ja fitnessprogramm für
deutschland auf eine antrag aber darin
ist ein unbestimmter wildwuchs von
forderungen aber
unabhängig von den afg anträgen ja das
thema inflation ist die herausforderung
der zeit es ist doch die soziale frage
und den otto marl und normalverdienern
in diesem land zerrinnt die kaufkraft
regelrecht zwischen den fingern und
besonders betroffen sind die die ohnehin
wenig verdienen und da ich sehr gern
noch mal an den armutsbericht corona hat
die armut in unserem land noch einmal
ansteigen lassen sie liegt jetzt auf
rekordniveau ach 13,8 millionen menschen
in deutschland sind arm jedes fünfte
kind in deutschland ist arm 17 prozent
der rentnerinnen und rentner ist und
dass während das privatvermögen ein jahr
weniger die höchststände erreicht hat
was ist das für eine bizarre entwicklung
vor allem auf eine schande in die meine
damen und herren sehr geehrte gegen die
kollegen der ampel gemischt und sagen ja
aber ich bin schon ein bisschen
enttäuscht auf ganzer linie dass ihre
entlastungs pakete so gestrickt werden
die wiener wunderkerzen einmal
angezündet sind sie schnell abgebrannt
und danitschek
so laufen ja nach den ferien ein euro
ticket ja auch der tank rabatt aber die
preise werden hoch bleiben und wenn
putin slots ihm ein dass dennoch zu
drehte dann wird es noch schlimmer und
neben dem darß preisschock fangen sie ja
sogar jetzt an die dazu gesetzliche
belastungen für die bürgerinnen bürger
zu verteilen bürger tests sind nicht
mehr kostenfrei 20 23 steigt der
zusatzbeitrag der gesetzlichen
krankenversicherung um 0,3 prozent der
macht zusammen rund 5 milliarden euro
mehrbelastung für die bürger und deshalb
sollten sie sich nicht so rüber bei den
30 milliarden paket denn sie sind längst
nicht ausreichen und das wissen sie und
die sind noch gut ausgewogen ein großer
teil der menschen in diesem land die
studenten studenten die rentnerin
rentner in die röhre geguckt haben
deshalb erwarten wir von ihnen ein neues
entlastungspaket verlängert sie
verlängern das neue ticket bis zum
jahresende setzten sich die
mehrwertsteuer bei den
grundnahrungsmittel auf null verdoppeln
sie die energiepreis pauschale und vor
allem beziehen sie die rentnerinnen und
rentner in diesem land endlich naht
vielleicht
christian görke finanzpolitischer
sprecher der linksfraktion er ist auch
schon mal finanzminister gewesen nämlich
in brandenburg und jetzt komplett ruben
aus der fdp-fraktion
wirtschaftspolitischer sprecher
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
ich habe eben noch mal im kirchner
geguckt sie waren ja
radiomoderator für
antenne mecklenburg vorpommern wenn ich
wenn ich die beiträge ihrer fraktionen
und ihren beitrag von eben höhere habe
ich eher das gefühl sie sind der
sprecher von radio moskau
in ihnen welche position wollen sie uns
bringen sie wollen uns bringen in eine
möglichst große abhängigkeit von
russland das ist die geschichte die sie
uns hier seit jahren erzählt sie wollen
dieses land von russland abhängig machen
und da machen wir nicht mit da machen
wir alle
und ich sage ihnen da gibt es
verschiedene wege
das ist einmal natürlich der ausbau der
regenerativen energien das ist zweitens
eine diese diversifizierung des einkaufs
nicht nur von öl gas und kohle sondern
natürlich auch von unterschiedlichsten
metallen
unterschiedlichsten rohstoffen insgesamt
und dort bewegt sich die bundesregierung
auf dem richtigen weg dann lassen sie
uns aber doch mal wirklich zu den zahlen
kommen
20 und 78 das sind nicht etwa verkehrte
lottozahlen das sind die inflationsraten
der usa
des vereinigten königreichs des
baltikums und der türkei und auch in
russland ihrem traumland haben wir eine
inflationsrate von 17 prozent also die
inflationsrate ist kein typisches
deutsches problem und insgesamt wir
können nicht zufrieden sein aber
insgesamt können wir feststellen nur in
deutschland und in den niederlanden ist
die inflationsrate im letzten monat
zurückgegangen das ist nun keinen grund
zu jubeln aber es zeigt uns doch dass
wir die richtigen maßnahmen ergriffen
habe
und meine damen und herren was kann
politik vorneweg machen was kann politik
vorne weg machen das auch langfristig
wirkt das ist eine seriöse haushalts und
finanzpolitik das ist eine seriöse
finanzpolitik und wir werden die
schuldenbremse mit dem nächsten haushalt
einhalten und das ist ein entscheidendes
signal gerade für die finanzmärkte und
sie wissen bei der gesamtbewertung des
euros ist natürlich die positionierung
deutschlands in diesem system ganz
entscheidend und natürlich haben wir
auch ein großes interesse daran weiter
dafür zu sorgen dass sie ziehen sie
nicht steigen denn in den letzten jahren
war es ja relativ unproblematisch bei
niedrigen zinsen die staatsverschuldung
zu erhöhen dieser zustand ist vorbei wir
werden einen mehr milliardenbelastung
haben in den nächsten jahren und
deswegen ist es unsere pflicht dafür zu
sorgen dass der haushalt wirklich
finanzpolitisch sauber bleibt und wie
die schuldenbremse einhalten und das
spiel vom markt her am meisten um
inflation zu verhindern und
natürlich können sie sagen es ist immer
zu wenig erwähne es ist immer zu wenig
und es ist nicht zielgenau und es ist
nicht gut genug ich kann nur feststellen
die leute die das neun euro ticket
nutzen die die zur tankstelle fahren und
die gehaltsabrechnung im juli bekommen
die werten schulden was märkten von den
aktivitäten dieser bundesregierung da
lassen wir uns auch nicht dumm reden
hier das ist wirklich etwas zu billiges
geklickt und
als ich den zweiten antrag gelesen aber
nicht gedacht ist schon wieder karneval
also die empfehlung der afd den
österreichischen warenkorb als grundlage
der inflations belastung in deutschland
verwendet hat schon einen gewissen ja
humoristischen aspekt bedienen gar nicht
zugetraut also ich finde es wirklich
einen tollen vorschlag dass wir
demnächst in deutschland den preis für
topfen dollar chen einbauen in die
berechnung unserer inflationsrate und
außerdem ich kann sie beruhigen es geht
auch noch um panierte schnitzel meine
damen und herren wenn die anträge der
afd auf dem niveau bleiben brauchen wir
uns politisch keine sorgen nach den
vielen dank
der wirtschaftspolitische sprecher der
fdp fraktion
zum zu den beiden anträgen der eigenen
fraktion auf die jetzt nochmal
röhnisch springer aus der fdp-fraktion
reagieren kann erst arbeits und
sozialpolitische sprecher
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren liebe gäste früher
konnte man für 50 euro einen vollen
einkaufswagen aus dem supermarkt
schieben heute ist er wegen der
inflation nur noch halb so voll diese
sätze hört man in diesen tagen
regelmäßig und man hört auch die sätze
die da oben belügen uns die inflation
ist in wahrheit viel höher die
statistiken sind getürmt und tatsächlich
gibt es eine immer größer werdende lücke
zwischen der offiziellen inflation und
der gefühlten inflation
und das hat eine ursache das liegt daran
dass die inflations messung in
deutschland über einen großen warenkorb
läuft mit 650 waren und dienstleistungen
da ist dabei die wurst das öl dabei
weizen nudeln aber auch fernseher auto
und waschmaschine und man kann
beobachten dass most öl und weizen nudel
immer teurer werden die preise
explodieren auf der anderen seite
bleiben die preise beim fernseher
waschmaschine recht konstant und so kann
es eben sein dass die gesamtinflation
bei 8 prozent liegt und das erleben wir
momentan aber die inflation im
supermarkt explodiert und das ergebnis
ist eben ein vertrauensverlust in den
staat und seine institutionen weil die
zahlen eben nicht mehr zur beobachtung
passen österreich hat auf dieses problem
reagiert und veröffentlichte neben der
allgemeinen inflationsrate auch
inflationsraten zu einem täglichen
kleinen einkauf und zu einem
wöchentlichen großeinkauf der
wöchentlichen großeinkauf was ist dass
bohnenkaffee batterien dort spiele aber
auch einmal tanken an der tankstelle die
tk pizza genauso wie parkgebühren und
siehe da während die allgemeine
inflation in österreich bei 7,7 prozent
liegt liegt die inflation des
wöchentlichen großeinkauf bei 15,4
prozent sie ist also doppelt zu hoch und
das ist genau das was die leute spüren
dieser massive teuerung und supermarkt
die nicht zu dem passt was sie den
leuten erzählen und das ist die führte
inflation diese gefühlte inflation macht
die leute fertig und das zerstört
vertrauen vertrauen in den staat wir als
alternative wir als alternative für
deutschland stehen für eine ehrliche
politik und deshalb fordern wir die
bundesregierung auf dem österreichischen
beispiel zu folgen und sich bei der
inflation ehrlich zu machen das heißt
wir wollen dass die bundesregierung
zukünftig nicht nur die daten zur
allgemeinen inflation veröffentlicht
sondern auch zum täglichen großeinkauf
und zum wöchentlichen zum täglichen
einkaufen zu wöchentlichen großeinkauf
wir wollen dass das vertrauen in den
staat und seine institutionen wieder
gestärkt wird und ich hoffe doch sehr
stark dass das auch in ihrem interesse
ist und auch in ihrem interesse werte
damen und herren der bundesregierung ich
bedanke mich für ihre aufmerksamkeit
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen auf der
ehrentribüne hat der präsident der
parlamentarischen versammlung des
europarats seine exzellenz herr teenie
cox mit seiner delegation platz genommen
im namen aller kolleginnen und kollegen
des deutschen bundestages begrüße ich
sie sehr herzlich bei uns
der deutsche bundestag mit 18
ordentlichen und 18 stellvertretenden
mitgliedern aus allen fraktionen in der
parlamentarischen versammlung des
europarats vertreten der europarat mit
46 mitgliedstaaten ist die bedeutendste
moment bedeutendste
menschenrechtsorganisation in europa und
hat entschlossen auf den russischen
angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine reagiert
die parlamentarische versammlung hat
eine entscheidende rolle für den
ausschluss russlands aus dem europarat
gespielt die wichtigste aufgabe des
europarats ist der schutz von
menschenrechten demokratie und
rechtsstaatlichkeit für ihren aufenthalt
bei uns und für ihr weiteres
parlamentarisches wirken begleiten sie
unsere besten wünsche
wir fahren fort in unserer debatte und
das wort erhält für die spd-fraktion der
kollege bernd westphal
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren wenn man über
die inflation in deutschland spricht
muss man sich vor allem mit den ursachen
beschäftigen und die liegen darin dass
wir seit dem 24 februar einen brutalen
angriffs krieg russlands in der ukraine
erleben an dessen bilder wir uns nicht
gewöhnen wollen deshalb hat diese
regierung in zusammenarbeit mit unseren
europäischen partnerinnen und partnern
mit der nato mit den usa ein
sanktionspaket erlassenen massnahmen
ergriffen ukrainerinnen und ukrainer zu
unterstützen und das hat natürlich auch
folgen für energieversorgung und auch
für die wirtschaftliche situation in
deutschland und das ist die ursache für
inflation und nicht die fehler dieser
bundesregierung meine sehr verehrten
erklären
es gibt große unterstützung für die
politik von der von olaf scholz
geführten bundesregierung und wir lassen
die menschen mit dieser situation nicht
alleine sondern wir haben jetzt schon
zwei hilfspakete auf den weg gebracht
die entlastung bedeuten für private
haushalte das sind 300 euro für jeden
beschäftigten
das sind für die kinder 20 euro das sind
viele unterstützungsmaßnahmen zur
entlastung von energiepreisen zum
beispiel mit der abschaffung ab ersten
juli der eeg umlage auf der
stromrechnung das merken die menschen ja
jetzt erst ist ja noch gar nicht richtig
angekommen wir haben die preisreduktion
an der zapfsäule und wir haben mit dem
neuen euro ticket pro monat eine
möglichkeit den öffentlichen
personennahverkehr stärker zu nutzen als
vielleicht bisher 30 milliarden
entlastung für die bevölkerung das ist
etwas wo diese bundesregierung die
menschen nicht alleine lässt mit
inflation
aber natürlich muss er unsere wirtschaft
gestärkt werden und auch dort gibt es
jetzt den rettungsschirm für unternehmen
die formen keine krieg betroffen sind
hier wird das entlastungen geben die
notifizierung sind kürzester zeit durch
das bundeswirtschaftsministerium
in der europäischen kommission erfolg
und von daher können diese woche anträge
beim bafa gestellt werden von
unternehmen die eine verdoppelung ihrer
energierechnung haben und hier auch
entlastung spüren und gleichzeitig haben
wir heute hier im hohen hause mehrere
gesetzespakete beschlossen die sich
genau auf den weg machen uns von
fossilen energien unabhängiger zu machen
und das ist der richtige weg nicht rein
in fossile nicht rein den kernenergie
sondern der zukunft gestalten für unser
land und für unsere wirtschaft
und weil es ein berechtigtes interesse
der arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
gibt in den zukünftigen
tarifverhandlungen natürlich auch dafür
zu sorgen dass die preissteigerung
ausgeglichen werden und jeder der sich
ein bisschen auskennt wie
tarifverhandlungen laufen ist dass
inflation und produktivität die dazu
führt auf basis von tarifgesprächen zu
sein und damit wir keine lohn preis
spirale bekommen hat der bundeskanzler
auf ein sehr bewährtes system gesetzt
nämlich die konzertierte aktion wo sich
die starke sozialpartnerschaft die
unseren standort stark gemacht hat jetzt
zusammensetzen und gemeinsam lösungen zu
das ist etwas
verantwortungsvolle politik wo man diese
bundesregierung nur beglückwünschen kann
dass sie unter der führung von urlaub
sollte das auf den weg bringt und dass
nicht die afg regiert die in ihrem
antrag schreibt dass politik vom
vertrauen der menschen lebt das was sie
hier vorführen dieses schmierentheater
verdient kein vertrauen und mein
bundesland niedersachsen der
verfassungsschutz hat sie deshalb unter
ein verdacht lag gestellt deshalb werden
sie genau beobachtet sie dürfen keine
verantwortung in diesem land erfahren
herzlichen dank
beim festmahl der wirtschaftspolitische
sprecher der spd-fraktion in der debatte
zu den beiden hfg anträgen zum thema
inflation in deutschland und zu diesem
thema hören jetzt klaus peter willsch
aus der union
haben die kollegen lieber zuschauer auf
der tribüne und den bildschirm die cdu
csu fraktion nimmt die sorgen der
menschen wegen der steigenden inflation
wegen der hohen inflation sehr ernst das
treibt die menschen um und das erfahren
wir jeden tag ein zufall
wir
müssen natürlich wir haben einzelne
maßnahmen dazu bereits debattiert hier
im hause das ganze auch von der
wirtschaftspolitik von der steuerpolitik
von der politischen seite her
unterstützen kampf gegen inflation wir
müssen haushalts wirtschaftlich solide
arbeiten und dürfen nicht geld ausgeben
als ob es kein morgen geben wir es
momentan noch zu erkennen ist bei der
ampel und
diese verantwortlichkeit vermissen dir
wir wissen aber auch dass ein kern des
problems war der linken im haus liegt
von grün bis ganz links
dass sie immer inflation als etwas
nachrangiges und etwas ungefährliches
ansehen das reicht der seine lange
tradition das reicht zurück bis zum
weltökonom helmut schmidt der seinerzeit
gesagt hat eben seinen fünf prozent
inflation lieber als fünf prozent
arbeitslosigkeit einen arbeitsplatz
diesen trade auf nämlich nicht man kann
sich nicht beliebig mit inflation
geschäft über kaufen
im kern und das muss hier nachlesen so
eine debatte auch angesprochen werden
der
verantwortlichkeit liegt natürlich am
ball hier die ezb die seit jahren eine
recht
also fahren waren verantwortungslose
geldpolitik macht wie ich mal sagen
möchte die auf teufel komm raus
liquidität schafft die bilanzen aufbläht
und die dann
an der zinsseite das problem hat
mit blick auf die hochverschuldeten
länder die hausaufgaben nicht gemacht
haben hat der euro zone mit der an der
zinsfront nicht reagieren zu können
kräftig genug wie es jetzt angezeigt
während wir müssen feststellen dass
durch die anleihekaufprogramme
unterschiedliche namens im grunde
genommen die
gesetzlich verbotene monetäre
staatsfinanzierung von der er zeitlebens
geben wird und ihr wird es eine aufgabe
sein gerade von der fdp aber ich habe da
oben eben gemerkt sie sind ja auch schon
in das andere lager ordnungspolitisch
gewechselt ordnungspolitisch gewechselt
hier werde es darauf ankommen dass man
in der diskussion im ecofin dass man in
den gremien kurs hält dass man nachher
auch personalpolitisch richtigen
entscheidungen trifft da gehören in die
ezb gremien in den rat des präsidium der
gehören nicht weich währungspolitiker
und irgendwelche juristen aus nur aus
auf die aus- und irgendwelche
irgendwelche juristinnen sondern da
gehören geldpolitiker der notenbanker
hin und da ist in der vergangenheit in
den zurückliegenden jahren
einiges schief gelaufen
ich glaube dass wir in dieser situation
in der wir uns befinden
appellieren müssen an die ezb ihren
auftrag ernst zu nehmen der einzige
grund warum es dieses gremium gibt
ist die deutsche erfahrung mit schweren
inflationen im zwanzigsten jahrhundert
mehrfach verlust vor allem was die
menschen hatten und das hat sie in einer
haltung kommen dass die es möglich
machte eine unabhängige bundesbank
einzuführen die alleine der
preisstabilität verpflichtet ist und das
modell übertragen auf die ezb ergebnis
das doch nicht zerstören lassen zwar die
erfolgreich sind zentral notenbank der
nachkriegszeit in europa und die ist
bedroht durch die versuche dieses zum
ersatzinstrument für
zu hause nicht finanzierbare oder nicht
durchsetzbar fiskalpolitik zu machen wir
müssen wir müssen dafür sorgen dass in
der dass die ezb geldpolitik macht und
die andere politik hier gemacht wird wer
geldpolitik macht soll es der ezb gehen
wer fiskalpolitik machen will der muss
ins parlament gehen da muss ich wählen
lassen der musste auseinandersetzung
stellen und gegeben fast sicher abwählen
lassen und deshalb müssen wir hier die
dinge wieder ein wenig vom kopf auf die
füße stellen die
die
situation die wir heute vorfinden
diese sucht nach schulden wird einen
harten geldpolitischen entzug nötig
machen um wirksam werden zu können wir
haben das historisch in der
wirtschaftsgeschichte in den 70er 80er
jahren alles schon erlebt natürlich ist
der grat immer schmal und droht bei sehr
kräftigen zins trainern der zinsschraube
negative auswirkungen auf konjunktur ob
er nochmal wie gesagt es ist ein
irrglaube es ist ein irrglaube
anzunehmen man könne mit dem laufen
lassen von inflation und der name einer
hohen inflation sich wachstum und und
und und stabile wirtschaft kaufen
stabile wirtschaft setzt solides
haushalten voraus daran lassen dies
müssen kommen sie dazu zurück das ist
der wichtigste beitrag denen die
bundespolitik hier in dieser situation
auch zur bekämpfung der inflation
leisten kann vielen dank klaus peter
willisch aus der unionsfraktion vor
wenigen jahren einer der erklärten
kritiker der hilfspakete für
griechenland und da auch außenseiter in
seiner fraktion gewesen oder einer von
einigen außenseitern und
überdies war er auch immer dafür dass in
griechenland den euro raum verlässt
nächste rednerin aus der fraktion
bündnis 90/die grünen und erste frau in
dieser debatte über die inflationsrate
in deutschland stefan f
vielen dank
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen in ihrer welt
möchte ich ja gerne leben ich suche mir
einfach ein teil des warenkorbes aus für
den ich noch bezahlen das andere spielt
für mich keine rolle weil anders kann
ich mir nicht erklären dass sie sagen
wir gucken auf einen teil der
inflationsrate sonst fühlen sich die
menschen belogen also muss ich
anscheinend für den anderen drei des
warenkorbs kein geld mehr ausgeben
inflation ist das thema das die menschen
in diesem land hier im moment stark
beschäftigt
dafür verantwortlich sind für fünf zu 50
prozent die stark gestiegenen energie
und lebensmittelpreise allerdings
betrifft die inflation genau und dadurch
bedingt mittlerweile weite teile des
warenkorbes doch anstatt sich mit
konstruktiven vorschlägen zu
beschäftigen die politik gezielt
inflation bekämpfen kann und diejenigen
entlasten kann die durch die inflation
in existenzielle not geraten
beschäftigt sich ihr antrag zu den
warenkörben mit der unterscheidung
zwischen gefühlter und nominaler
inflation nachdem
nachdem sie also jahrelang über gefühlte
sicherheitslage oder gefühlte migration
gesprochen haben nehmen sie nun gefühlte
inflation ins visier mit der
unterscheidung zwischen
evidenzbasiert und anekdotisch haben sie
sich ja schon bei anderen krisenlagen
schwer getan nur weil mein opa der wie
ein schlot geraucht hat über 90 jahre
alt ist kann ich trotzdem nicht die
aussage treffen das rauchen nicht
gesundheitsschädlich ist das ist der
unterschied zwischen anekdotisch und
evidenzbasiert sie fordern nun
die zusätzliche ausweisung der
inflationsrate für waren nach
österreichischem vorbild der warenkorb
der der ermittlung des
verbraucherpreisindexes und der
inflationsrate durch das statistische
bundesamt zugrunde liegt erhält eine
möglichst repräsentative auswahl von
gütern und dienstleistungen ihrer
meinung nach fühlen bürger in beim
täglichen oder wöchentlichen einkauf
aber eine andere inflation als die die
statistisch ermittelt wurde sie
bräuchten die unterschiedlichen
inflationsraten für ihre
konsumentscheidung wenn man dieser logik
folgt würden menschen ihre
konsumentscheidungen ja davon abhängig
machen ich war es auch bezüglich des
krieges in der ukraine vertreten sie
nennen wir es mal abweichende positionen
fakt ist dass putin die ukraine
völkerrechtswidrig angegriffen hat und
er macht in seinen äußerungen sehr klar
dass er deren existenz recht infrage
stellt und während alle vor allem
energiepreise für die inflation
verantwortlich machen die durch den
krieg ausgelöst ist sehen nennen sie die
geldpolitik der ezb
vielleicht gehen sie aber auch davon aus
dass der krieg möglichst schnell vorbei
ist wir sehen das anders so wie nahezu
alle
sicherheitsberater ihnen weltweit diese
situation wird länger andauern die
menschen haben also gar nicht die wahl
konsumentscheidungen zu verschieben wenn
der kühlschrank oder die waschmaschine
kaputt ist dann müssen sie sie ersetzen
und dann spiel auch das eine rolle für
die inflation die sie merkten
bürgerinnen brauchen handelnde politiker
innen und wir sind durchaus in der lage
auch ohne diese zusätzliche statistische
größe zu handeln wir beschäftigen uns
lieber mit maßnahmen und setzen diese um
wir haben den reiz kosten zum schutz für
wohngeldempfänger ihnen auf den weg
gebracht haben den grundfreibetrag an
bogen wir haben das nur ein euro ticket
auf den weg gebracht einen kinder sofort
zuschlag und einmalzahlungen für
empfängern von arbeitslosengeld 1 und 2
und vor allen dingen arbeiten wir seit
monaten daran die abhängigkeit die
einseitige von fossilen energien aus
russland zu beenden wir haben gerade
heute ein riesiges paket beschlossen um
mit dem ausbau von erneuerbaren energien
die ursache der inflation zu bekämpfen
hier verleugnen sie aber das problem
sogar gänzlich anders kann ich mir nicht
erklären dass sie glauben in einem ende
der sanktionen oder eine inbetriebnahme
von nord stream 2 wäre das problem hier
erledigt wir verstehen unserem auftrag
anders wir haben dafür sorge zu tragen
dass es nicht schule macht dass der
stärkere einfach den schwächeren
überfallen kann wir verteidigen
internationales recht und gleichzeitig
arbeiten wir daran dass wir vor allen
dingen diejenigen schützen die durch die
inflation in existenzielle not geraten
um nur ein beispiel zu nennen wir
arbeiten an der einführung der
kindergrundsicherung zu all diesen
aufgaben kommen touren ihn nichts außer
vorschläge aus der mottenkiste wir
arbeiten die bahn lösungen
stefanie öffne aus der fraktion bündnis
90 die grünen hat sich offensichtlich
etwas detaillierter beschäftigt mit den
beiden anträgen der afg zum thema
inflation in deutschland dass es auch
die debatte die wir gerade haben und bei
der wir jetzt warten auf karsten klein
aus der fdp fraktion
und er ist obmann im haushaltsausschuss
und im rechnungsprüfungsausschuss mit
zahlen kennt er sich folglich aus
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die inflation
trifft uns alle keine frage aber sie
trifft vor allem die schwächsten in
unserer gesellschaft die bei den jetzt
schon finanziell eng ist es trifft aber
auch die arbeitsplätze wenn wir über
verbraucher und erzeuger
preissteigerungen von fast 30 prozent
sprechen aber uns vielleicht noch mal
politisch auch korrekt einzuordnen
die hauptaufgabe zur bekämpfung von
inflation für die haltung von
geldwertstabilität sind die
zentralbanken das ist die ezb das ist
die zentrale aufgabe und dass auch hier
noch mal klar zu benennen und wenn wir
uns jetzt die beschlüsse aus dem juni
des ezb-rats anschauen dann müssen wir
zwar feststellen dass die politik der
letzten jahre in der form nicht
fortgesetzt wird eine abkehr aber von
einer expansiven geldpolitik ist damit
noch nicht festzustellen und deshalb
kann man sich zu recht fragen tut die
ezb genug tut sie zu wenig tut sich zu
spät ich will es klar beantworten ja
denn schon seit im juli 2021 sind die
preissteigerungen in europa deutlich
über dem zielwert von 2 prozent und
deshalb sein handeln im juni 22 einfach
zu spät liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
aber zu recht hält natürlich auch die
frage gestellt was kann fiskalpolitisch
was kann auf dem politischen parkett
getan werden und die frage müssen wir
uns durchaus stellen wie können wir in
dieser inflations in diesem
inflationsumfeld diesem hohen
inflationsumfeld was können wir
flankieren tanz politik beitragen
will aber nicht müde werden an der
stelle vielleicht darauf hinweisen weil
die union ja so viele vorhinein
gefordert hat darauf hinzuweisen dass es
glaube ich niemanden europa aufgefallen
ist dass in den letzten vier jahren die
deutschland an seite der soliden staaten
beim thema geld politik gestanden hat
sondern dass wir uns dank dankbar sein
müssen zum beispiel bei den kollegen aus
den niederlanden aus anderen ländern
dass es eine solide politik in deutsch
in europa gegeben hat liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen der union aber was können
wir tun um zu flankieren wir können zum
beispiel preis steigernde maßnahmen
staatlicherseits zurücknehmen wie wir
das zum beispiel sehr erfolgreich beim
tank rabatt getan haben wie wir das bei
der abschaffung der eeg-umlage getan
haben damit hat die bundesregierung hat
diese ampel hat bundesfinanzminister
lindner ja gezeigt dass wir bereit sind
dämpfend auf preisentwicklungen
einzugehen und die inflationsrate die
aktuell in diesem monat festgestellt
worden ist zeigt ja dass wir den
richtigen weg ergriffen haben
aber natürlich gelten in solchen zeiten
auch dass man auf der ausgabenpolitik
dämpfend wirkt und da will ich einfach
noch mal darauf hinweisen natürlich sind
wir krisenbedingt liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen der union von einem
bundeshaushalt von
572 milliarden euro im soll 2021
hergekommen übrigens bei einer planung
von ursprünglich war 360 milliarden euro
das sind schon erhebliche unterschiede
wie gesagt krisenbedingt mut zu
begründen aber wir führen dass jetzt
über 495 milliarden euro 22 auf 445
milliarden 2023 und dann 422 milliarden
2024 ampel-koalition zurück und es zeigt
dass bundesminister finanzminister
christian lindner auf den richtigen weg
ist wenn er einen konsolidierungspfad
einführt so wie wir das im
koalitionsvertrag ja auch gemeinsam
festgelegt haben
denn liebe kolleginnen kollegen wir sind
ja nicht krisenfrei wir haben ja nach
wie vor die korona krise wo wir kosen
maßnahmenprogramme vor allem des
ehemaligen bundesgesundheitsministers
wir in spa noch ab finanzieren müssen
wir haben zu schultern die gkv
steigerungen viele gesetzgebungen auch
der union also nur damit sie sich hier
nicht aus der verantwortung stehlen
können aber wir betreiben eine soliden
konsolidierungskurs wenn es um schicht
die staatsfinanzen geht denn liebe
kolleginnen kollegen in einer hoch
inflationsphase darf der staat nicht nur
inflationstreibend wegen sondern muss
sich zurücknehmen und deshalb ist es
genau so richtig und damit komme ich zum
schluss dass in einer solchen phase der
staat nicht noch inflations gewinner ist
und deshalb müssen wir in der koalition
jetzt engagiert über die bekämpfung der
kalten progression sprechen damit dass
auch antizipiert werden kann bei den
anstehenden lohnverhandlungen damit es
keine los nun preisspirale gibt und dass
die kollegen kollegen auffordern an
dieser wichtigen stelle nochmal
nachzuarbeiten über die sommerpause
nachzudenken damit wir dann im herbst
die kalte progression bekämpfen können
vielen dank
da war es mal wieder das phänomen der
kalten progression ein bericht dazu wie
den tatsächlich da der stand der dinge
es wie groß das ausmaß möglicher weise
ist den wird es allerdings erst im
herzen leben habe ich anfang dieser
woche gelernt und dann kann man das
ganze auch mal mit konkreten zahlen
unterlägen annika klose ist hier die
drittletzte rednerin in dieser debatte
sie ist mitglied im ausschuss für arbeit
und soziales und der spd fraktion
schlägt mit fast fünf euro zu buche und
die preise für ein paket nudeln die
haben sich fast verdoppelt schon beim
kleinen einkauf können so schnell über
20 euro in der kasse zusammen vielen
menschen die an so einer kasse stehen
tut das weh die preise auf der anzeige
so schnell hoch schnell zu sehen nicht
nur weil sie sich sorgen machen ob sie
diesen einkauf am ende vielleicht doch
gar nicht sich leisten können sondern
auch weil immer die frage im hinterkopf
mitschwingt kann ich nächste woche
überhaupt noch einkaufen und wie ist das
mit den stromnachzahlung mutti kocht im
nächsten winter diese sorgen und nöte
sind real und ich möchte sagen wir sehen
diese sorgen und diese nöte wir sehen
sie und wir nehmen sie sehr ernst seien
sie versichert wir tun unser möglichstes
um abhilfe zu schaffen damit der kleine
und der große einkaufstempel ist und
auch die stromrechnung kein
damoklesschwert über den köpfen der
menschen sein wird
nun stellt sich natürlich die frage wie
in dieser situation am besten abhilfe
geschaffen werden kann insbesondere bei
denjenigen mit kleinen und mittleren
einkommen die gerade probleme haben über
die runden zu kommen die völlig
unzureichende antwort der
fdp-bundestagsfraktion finden wir den
beiden vorliegenden anträgen die wir
hier diskutieren
einerseits wollen sie die inflations
berechnungen auf warenkörbe und stellen
da kann man mal abwägen sogar drüber
reden am ende hilft es den menschen nur
dabei zu berechnen was sie sich jetzt
alles nicht mehr leisten können und
sagte kein cent mehr im portemonnaie an
der freibadkasse
andererseits fordern sie ein ominöses
fitnessprogramm für deutschland
naja eigentlich finde ich wenn man das
so liest kann man sich wirklich nur an
den kopf fassen ein fitnessprogramm ich
würde ihnen eigentlich eher empfehlen
vielleicht mal ein bisschen mehr
denksport zu machen und anstatt sich
eben hierüber mit schlechten witzen auf
den kosten der betroffenen lustig zu
machen
daher kennen wir doch mal zurück zu dem
angesprochen und problem nämlich der
sogenannten station an der station
das bedeutet eine situation mit
steigenden preisen also hohe inflation
mit niedrigen wirtschaftswachstum und
hoher arbeitslosigkeit und der grund
dafür sind knappe güter also die
angebotsseite was ist also in dieser
situation zu tun mit erlaubnis der
präsidentin zitiere ich zu dieser frage
den geschäftsführer des münchner
ifo-instituts clemens fuest der im
bayrischen rundfunks folgendes dazu
erklärt hat zitat das angebot verknappt
sich hier in dem fall vor allem das
energieangebot und dadurch werden die
preise in die höhe getrieben und darauf
kann die politik eigentlich nur
reagieren indem man gezielt hilfen für
die ganz stark betroffenen gibt die dann
alle gemeinsam tragen zitat ende sehr
geehrte damen und herren das ist doch
wieder ein sehr guter beleg dafür warum
es gut ist dass wir unsere abwehr
regierung haben die sich genau dieses
leben derzeit sich vorgenommen haben
und es muss jetzt darum gehen als er die
menschen in dem land besonders zu
unterstützen die schwierigkeiten haben
über die runden zu kommen und genau das
machen wir auch schon dafür nämlich
nehmen nämlich 30 milliarden euro in die
hand mit unseren entlastungs paket mit
dem familienbonus mit dem familienbonus
sowie sind 300 euro energie geld für
erwerbstätige hat eine vierköpfige
familie jetzt kurzfristig 800 euro
brutto mehr zur verfügung mit 200 euro
einmalzahlung den kinder sofort
zuschlagen den heizkostenzuschuss für
wohngeldempfänger erschaffen wir abhilfe
für alle menschen in den sozialen
sicherung mit der absenkung der energie
steuer und dem neuen euro ticket
ermöglichen wir es viele menschen trotz
der steigenden kosten von a nach b zu
kommen und sogar vielleicht in einen
kleinen urlaub zu fahren außerdem darf
das neue euro ticket die inflation und
es somit auf allen ebenen ein voller
erfolg
mit der waffe mit der bank
unterstützen wir studierenden und mit
der einführung des mindestlohns zum
ersten oktober ab 12 euro und der
höchsten rentenerhöhung seit jahrzehnten
und ost und west haben wir maßnahmen
beschlossen die jetzt schon wirken und
damit sind wir noch nicht am ende der
fahnenstange angekommen
bundeskanzler olaf scholz hat vor
wenigen wochen die konzertierte aktion
angekündigt und hat das gespräch mit
gewerkschaften und arbeitgeberverbänden
verbänden bereits erfolgreich angestoßen
dann nur gemeinsam und solidarisch
können wir eben aus der aktuellen lage
herausfinden zum anfang des nächsten
jahres werden wir als ampel das neue
bürgergeld einführen möchten damit
grundsicherungs empfängerinnen
unterstützen und entlasten orientiert an
deren bedarfen und deren wünschen und
natürlich werden wir den kommenden
wochen über weitere entlastung reden
dass liebe bürgerinnen und bürger ist
die politik die sorgen und nöte ernst
nimmt und abhilfe schafft was die fdp
ihrem fitnessprogramm hier veranstaltet
ist hingegen der versuch sich auf kosten
dieser sorgen und nöte der bevölkerung
zu definieren und das hilft genau
niemanden daher sind diese anträge
abzulehnen wie ihre kolleginnen kollegen
vielen dank
annika klose aus der spd fraktion mit
ihrer sicht auf die anträge der die zum
thema inflation in deutschland die hier
diskutiert werden es kommen noch zwei
redner in dieser debatte zunächst
sebastian brehm aus der cdu/csu-fraktion
mitglied der csu landesgruppe liebe frau
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
ich möchte mit drei zahlen beginnen die
inflation in deutschland ist mit rund
acht prozent so hoch wie seit
jahrzehnten nicht zweiter zahl
im mai hatte deutschland einen außen
bilanz
handelsdefizit einen monat mit einem
solchen aus
handelsbilanzdefizit gab es letztes mal
deutschland verspielt gerade seinen
titel als exportweltmeister und die
dritte zahl liebe kolleginnen kollegen
im juni ist die arbeitslosigkeit in
deutschland um 100.000 gestiegen auf 236
millionen arbeitslose und all diese drei
zahlen zeigen dass es höchste zeit wird
dass sie als ampel zielgerichtet nicht
im streik sondern zielgerichtet handeln
und deutschlands zukunft nicht im
klein-klein und in ihrer umverteilungs
idee kaputt machen wir mit kollegen
kollegen die energiepreise steigen und
die antwort des wirtschaftsministers
habeck ist wir müssen im pullover
anziehen oder weniger duschen die
lebensmittelpreise steigen und
landwirtschaftsland wirtschaftsminister
özdemir und finanzminister lindner
belasten die landwirte erheblich anstatt
zu entlasten und liebe kolleginnen
kollegen der deutsche mittelstand kommt
bei ihnen in der ampel regierung
überhaupt nicht mehr mit keiner silbe
vor nur mit mehr bürokratie und mit
mehrausgaben und ich meinte es in allem
ernst sie haben den ernst dieser lage
nicht verstanden und wenn sie jetzt
nicht zielgerichtet handeln dann kommen
wir in wirklich schwere zeiten für die
industrie in wirklich schwere zeiten für
den deutschen mittelstand und den
schwere zeiten für die bürgerinnen und
bürger und sie tun nichts oder wenn im
klein klein und schauen zehnten auges zu
was da passiert sie schädigen damit den
standort deutschland den wohlstand in
unserem land und sie machen die menschen
in unserem land ärmer liebe kolleginnen
kollegen von der ampel
vielleicht zum ersten punkt nicht nur
parolen sie reden viel und tun nichts
beim ersten punkt inflation und sie
könnten hier was tun wie gesagt die
inflationsrate ist bei 8 prozent so hoch
wie nie zuvor und gleichzeitig sprudeln
die steuereinnahmen wenn sich der
butterpreis verdoppelt erhöhen sich die
doppelt soviel die
mehrwertsteuereinnahmen des
finanzministers auch wenn sich die löhne
erhöhen erhöht sich über die kalte
progression die einkommensteuereinnahmen
des finanzministers und deswegen fordern
wir sie auf und wir es können wir nicht
oft genug sagen die mehreinnahmen die
sie in deutschen haushalt haben an die
bürgerinnen und bürger und im deutschen
mittelstand zurückzugeben gerade jetzt
in der zeit
und wenn sie inflation wirksam eindämmen
wollen dann brauchen wir einen
ausgeglichenen haushalt und interessant
ist sie sprechen von einem
ausgeglichenen haushalt der kollege
janitschek sagt im herbst müssen wir
darüber reden den ausgeglichenen
haushalt zurückzunehmen sie dürfen nicht
weiter diese rekordschulden politik wie
in diesem jahr fortsetzen wir brauchen
eine schwarze null beim nächsten
haushalt
und zweitens sie müssten überlegen
themen haben sich inzwischen fragen
selbstverständlich gern
kollege prem danke dass ihr die
zwischenfrage zu schauen wie es schon
langsam ganz schwindelig von ihren
widersprüchen die sie damit sich selber
formulieren in ihrer rede zum einen
hatten sie uns vor dass wir nicht solide
genug mit den haushaltsmitteln umgehen
gleichzeitig hat die union vorschläge
gemacht die weit über das hinausgehen in
der frage der energie steuersenkung
beispielsweise was wir vorgenommen haben
das ist der eine widerspruch und dann
möchte ich auf das thema mittelstand
eingehen ich war vor zwei tagen auch mit
kollegen ihrer fraktion bei der
glasindustrie haben sie zur kenntnis
genommen dass die bundesregierung in
diesen tagen gerade die notifizierung
auf die europäischen union durchgesetzt
hat dass wir über 5 milliarden euro
hilfe gerade für den mittelstand für
energieintensive unternehmen in die hand
genommen haben also wir helfen da
wirklich zielgerichtet übrigens gerade
auch für bayern für oberfranken
lieber kollege jan dietrich oder
mittelbar unsere vorschläge sind
komplett gegen finden sie wir brauchen
in unserem land wachstum wir brauchen in
unserem land wachstum wenn wir vorher
entlasten werden wir mit innovation mit
investitionen wachstum erzeugen wenn sie
aber jetzt im mittelstand nicht
entlasten dann kommen weniger
steuereinnahmen und der haushalt wird
schlechter insofern ist es mittel und
langfristig gegenfinanzieren und sie
müssen halt auch mal im haushalt
einsparen jedes programm was kommt wird
ausgegeben jedes geld wird ausgegeben
sie müssten einsparen und hier gibt es
ja zahlreiche vorschläge die sie
durchsetzen könnten wir kommen da im
haushalt auch noch mal in der ersten
sitzungswoche nach der sommerpause
darauf zu und das zweite natürlich
brauchen wir eine entlastung im
mittelstand bei den energiekosten es ist
vielleicht ein schritt aber nehmen sie
einen normalen mittelständler der
vielleicht 50.000 euro energiekosten hat
und preissteigerung von 300 bis 500
prozent wie soll der im monat diese
preis steuerung auf die preise umlegen
können das wird er nicht schaffen
deswegen wenn sie hier keine reduzierung
vornehmen werden wir im nächsten jahr
spätestens wenn die kontrakte der
mittelständler auslaufen in ein
erhebliches risiko
kommen dass wir insolvenz in unserem
land sehen und deswegen müssen sie jetzt
zielgerichtet entlasten aber sie tun
wesentlich zu wenig liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
und deswegen sage ich wir brauchen bei
inflation senkung der pendlerpauschale
zielgerichtete entlastung bei den 300
euro die rentner kriegen es nicht die
minister bekommen es aber wir brauchen
auch und da werden wir heute abend
übrigens heute abend übrigens namentlich
darüber abstimmen auch eine verlängerung
der atomkraftwerke und da bin ich
gespannt ob der die fdp die draußen rum
rennen und sagt wir brauchen es auch bei
diesem antrag heute namentlich zustimmt
liebe kolleginnen und wir brauchen
natürlich
ein vorziehen der dringend notwendigen
abschaffung der kalten progression
wenn sie das nicht tun machen sie die
menschen automatisch ärmer und beim
zweiten thema wettbewerbsfähigkeit außen
handelsbilanzdefizit wir haben die
höchsten steuern für unternehmen in der
gesamten oecd
wenn sich hier nichts tun und biss haben
haben sie im mittelstand hier gar nichts
gemacht obwohl die fdp dies im wahlkampf
angekündigt hat gar nichts gemacht dann
nehmen sie den unternehmen das geld für
notwendige investitionen für notwendige
innovation und das geld für notwendiges
wachstum aber wir werden nur mit
wachstum aus dieser krise herauskommen
also wenn sie nichts tun machen sie die
unternehmen ärmer und wir brauchen ein
belastungsmoratorium in jedem gesetz was
sie auf den weg bringen allein die 300
euro klima geld haben elf paragrafen
einkommensteuer ab sie belasten die
bürokratie sie belastende mehrausgaben
hören sie damit auf gerade in der
jetzigen zeit brauchen wir ein
belastungsmoratorium für den deutschen
mittelstand liebe kolleginnen kollegen
und vielleicht der letzte punkt
arbeitslosigkeit
und ich meinte es mit allem ernst
sie haben in den letzten wochen die
aussetzung der sanktionen
in der grundsicherung beschlossen wie
soll denn ein jobcenter jemanden in die
arbeit schicken wenn er keine sanktionen
mehr zu befürchten hat wir haben
hunderttausend mehr arbeitslose und
gleichzeitig wollen wir arbeitskräfte
aus dem ausland zu führen damit wir
diesen arbeitsmarkt überhaupt schaffen
wie wollen sie das schaffen diese abkehr
vom prinzip fordern und fördern ist
gerade jetzt in dieser zeit fatale
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir gehen in die sommerpause ich denke
dass wir uns nicht ausruhen können sie
dürfen sich nicht aus und sie müssen aus
ihrem liegestuhl raus und in der
sommerpause echte notwendige
entscheidungen treffen damit wir aus
dieser krise herauskommen ansonsten
werden wir im herbst auf erhebliche da
mache ich mir wirklich sorgen auf
erhebliche probleme stoßen in allen
bereichen unsere wirtschaft und bei den
bürgerinnen und bürger und das ist
alleine ihre verantwortung liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der ampel
sebastian brehm war das aus der
unionsfraktion hat der ampelkoalition
ins gewissen geredet wir können
nachschieben 20
gesetzesänderungen beziehungsweise
verordnung hat die ampel fraktion und
die bundesregierung rund um das thema
erneuerbare energien auf den weg
gebracht heute und größtenteils schon
verabschiedet sebastian roloff aus der
spd fraktion ist der letzte redner in
dieser debatte oder die
volkswirtschaftlichen seminare nicht
zugucken also war das niveau war
wirtschaftspolitisch und wirklich
erstaunlich und ich hoffe dass wir
wenigstens noch mal nachlesen was hier
teilweise für widersprüche und teilweise
einfach für absolute fehler schenkt news
und das thema fake news und tram pesce
politik ist heute in london gescheitert
zb
vorgenommen werden nicht versucht gerne
was zur aufklärung beizutragen
wir werden uns glaube ich zunächst mal
zumindest einig auch wenn es nicht viel
weiter gehen das wäre die inflation
bekämpfen will an die ursachen der
inflation muss und dann hören wir immer
als als großes general rezept
insbesondere aus der rechten seite des
hauses wir brauchen höhere zinsen um
eine senkung der staatsausgaben
das ist ja immer das große job macht das
könnte auch wichtig sein wenn wir über
einen nachfrage-boom legen würden der
die inflation auslöst ist das in dem
fall so gucken wir es uns doch mal an
wir gucken uns die löhne an löhne haben
sich in den letzten zwei jahren mit
blick auf die korona pandemie mit
einmalzahlung mit zur lohnzurückhaltung
der gewerkschaften nur sehr schwach
anders als in anderen westlichen ländern
übrigens entwickelt wir sind die
konsumquote dieser zehn jahren fällt und
wir sehen eine zunehmend schwächere
auftragslage in der industrie es ist
ganz offensichtlich nicht nachfrage
gesteuert wer die inflation diesem boom
zuschreibt und dann auf steigende zinsen
und ausgabenkürzungen um reitet schüttet
öl ins feuer und kein wasser und da wäre
ich tatsächlich froh ich bin gleich
drauf wenn wir über volkswirtschaftliche
grundkenntnisse reden würden und auf der
basis unsere rezepte entwickelt und
nicht auf der basis von ideologie
ja das thema ezb sei immer schön sie
fordern eine unabhängige ezb wo sich die
politik nicht einmischen darf sagen dann
aber lieber ezb ihr müsstet erst 23 doch
der nächste widerspruch es ist doch
einfach nicht logisch und wenn wir uns
angucken was die situation jetzt
ausgelöst hat wir haben einen
angebotsschock wir haben explodierender
energiepreise wir haben probleme bei den
lieferketten rohstoffengpässe ganz
offensichtlich und auch ganz
offensichtlich durch was ist ausgelöst
wird die sind der grund für die
inflation da müssen wir ran und nicht an
die üblichen ideologischen die üblichen
ideologischen rezepte die gefahr einer
stagnation ist präsent es kann passieren
dass müssen wir alle im auge haben und
wenn wir uns dann immer gegenseitig
unterstellen wir würden das nicht ernst
nehmen wird es dem ernst der lage glaube
ich nicht gerecht weiteres problem ist
der fachkräftemangel allen betrieben und
ich unterstelle dass wir alle regelmäßig
in betrieben oder bei den ihk es
unterwegs sind heißt wir brauchen
fachkräfte und wir brauchen nicht nur
fachkräfte wir brauchen arbeitskräfte
wir haben auch einen arbeitskräftemangel
ich verzichte jetzt mal drauf zu
erklären wer zuwanderungs themen
fachkräfte zuwanderung die letzten 16
jahre erfolgreich verhindert hat wir
haben das angegangen und bin froh dass
wir die entsprechenden maßnahmen als
ampel hier schon auf den weg gebracht
haben
wir brauchen zielgerichtete maßnahmen um
die steigenden preise zu dämpfen
insbesondere für die menschen die in
sozialer not sind da ist der erste teil
der wirkung des entlastungspaket schon
passiert meine kolleginnen und kollegen
sind darauf eingegangen ein großteil der
wirkung kommt jetzt aber in den nächsten
wochen nun monaten erst und
dementsprechend ist da ein wichtiger
schritt gemacht ich verhehle aber auch
nicht dass wir die situation natürlich
im auge behalten müssen und jetzt schon
diskutieren müssen zumindest welche
optionen wird zur weiterentwicklung im
herbst haben ich persönlich habe große
sympathie für die position der dgb
vorsitzenden zum beispiel die über einen
strom- und gaspreis deckel für
privathaushalte
nachgedacht hat habe ich große sympathie
frank schiff gemacht den daumen hoch
fahrzeugen zum protokoll nicht vermerkt
ist schon mal gut
entsprechend kann man darüber reden das
ist auch kein sozialismus oder keine
planwirtschaft wie bis heute gehört
haben zu machen die französischen
freundinnen und freunde sehr erfolgreich
und jetzt kann man über immanuel makro
insbesondere mit blick auf seine
koalitionsoptionen viel sagen aber nicht
dass der sozialist sei und dass neun
euro gibt es ganz offensichtlich ein
riesenerfolg und das sollten wir zum 365
euro ticket weiterentwickeln aber
natürlich auch die
regionalisierungsmittel erhöhen weil wo
kein bart keine bahn und kein bus hin
fährt kann man ihn auch nicht nehmen und
dafür brauchen wir nun mal geld und das
muss auf den weg gebracht werden die
unternehmen müssen auf der kostenseite
entlastet werden das ist richtig
insbesondere die energieintensiven
unternehmen und wir müssen bei den
finanzmarkt spekulationen eingrenzen
damit die rohstoffpreise nicht weiter
durch die decke gehen wir müssen die
wertschöpfungsketten restrukturieren
wertschöpfungsketten und wir müssen
selbstverständlich autark von russischer
energie und vom knappen rohstoffen
werden dazu haben wir heute im haus auch
noch mehr debatte dementsprechend kann
ich in der zeit bleiben
bedanke mich für die aufmerksamkeit und
hoffe dass wir unsere rolle als aktiver
staat der eine aktive wirtschaftspolitik
macht begreifen und entsprechende
investitionen und maßnahmen auf den weg
bringen vielen dank
sebastian roloff war das für die spd
fraktion und der am ende hat er gesagt
er könne gut in der zeit bleiben das ist
dem bundestag insgesamt bisher ganz gut
gelungen gerade mal fünf minuten verzug
im vergleich zur planung von heute
morgen noch das ist schon ziemlich
stattlich vor allem angesichts der
vielen namentlichen abstimmungen die es
heute vormittag ja gegeben hat rund um
den bereich erneuerbare energien also
hier geht es jetzt weiter mit
überweisungen im vereinfachten verfahren
also tagesordnungspunkte ohne debatte
ist gibt dann anschließend in gut 25
minuten ungefähr die aktuelle stunde auf
antrag der afg zur gasversorgung in
deutschland und da hat die afd die idee
doch einfach nord stream zwei in betrieb
zu nehmen dann hätte deutschland ja
genug gas auch aus russland das wird
recht kontrovers diskutiert werden da
bin ich ziemlich sicher durch diese
debatte wird sie dann gleich katharina
kühn begleiten wir machen eine kurze
unterbrechung unserer übertragung aus
dem bundestag denn wir wissen auch in
einer anderen europäischen hauptstadt
ist heute vergleichsweise viel los
gewesen deswegen gehe ich erstmal ab was
berlin nach bonn und so hans-werner